when Courtney Whitmore found out her
stepfather used to be a superhero
sidekick she donned his costume for
herself of course she had a tailored now
wielding the power of her cosmic staff
she performs heroic deeds as star girl
star girl is a nimble blaster prefers to
use her cosmic staff for crowd control
and sudden damage her passive is family
heirlooms which gives star girl
additional movespeed unless she's taken
damage cosmic blast delivers a line of
energy that deals power damage to all
enemies hit as part of family heirlooms
cosmic blast deals additional power
damage over a short duration equal to a
percent of the target's current health
shooting stars fires a star that marks
the target for small stars appear and
automatically fire at the marked target
didn't power damage to the first enemy
they hit enemies caught in gravity well
lose movespeed
and take additional damage from star
girls other skills her ultimate is
energy conversion star girl tethers an
enemy champion dealing power damage over
time and converting a percent of that
damage into a shield while tether the
enemy is crippled making them unable to
- rush link or benefit from bonus moves
speed
Stargirl can move during energy
conversion but if her target moves too
far away whatever is broken when in lane
use cosmic blasts long range to chip
away your enemy's health warning
shooting stars can force your enemy to
avoid the incoming homing stars making
it great for in lane harassment to avoid
shooting stars enemy champions will
often run behind enemy drones so use
this chance to land a cosmic blast
gravity well is best used to escape when
alone or to ensure a kill with your
allies if an enemy pushes too far into
your lane take advantage of the
situation by placing gravity well behind
them follow up with cosmic blast and
shooting star which will deal more
damage because of gravity well if your
opponent has crowd control like stunned
or silenced wait for the skill to go on
cooldown before using energy conversion
otherwise an enemy can break the tether
for instance a champion like the Joker
can simply use mr. punchy to interrupt
the ultimate because energy conversion
can [ __ ] and provide a temporary
shield using it to escape can sometimes
be the difference between a safe exit or
defeat star girls consume grants power
damage while on kill them when playing
solo Lane it can help you keep drone
waves pushed out and provide good health
sustain try to keep this stolen power on
cooldown for the constant increase in
power damage when building star girls
artifacts power damage and power
penetration are your best
start with a nil ring for some will
regen and early-game power damage
fittingly a great artifact for star girl
is her very own cosmic staff as its
disintegration effect will stack with
her passives damage over time to get
more will sustain early on build tier 2
of dr. Destiny's dream stone for more
power damage you can always rely on star
heart if you're falling behind the lane
opponent a more defensive build will
reduce their advantage for attack armor
useful artifacts include neurons
contract or Steel's breastplate for
power armor trio' a gambit or eclipses
diamond
blast your opponent's into cosmic dust
as starter